hi reject nation it's Greg Alba here and
I'm John guys guess what today is
it's June 12th do you know what June
12th is John Humphrys birthday do you
guys know what John wants for his
birthday I would like for you guys to
listen to us shamelessly promote our
upcoming event at the arena city lounge
on July the 7th it's a Saturday people
Saturday John and I are gonna be hosting
our very first live event arena Santa
lounger II and Chandler is gonna be
moderating the questions for us because
it is inspired by her film therapy
segment which John and I have been on
Stacy Howard will also be there it's
gonna be a really fun time it's gonna be
a very personal intimate event there's
only 50 seats available so only the
first 50 who get tickets will actually
be able to come out and participate in
this event for a molasses-like some real
personal questions actually and and
they'll actually also link to our
experiences with film if you've ever
seen our film therapy segment you'll see
that it gets some really personal stuff
in there beyond us just doing that we
want to hang out with you guys before
during and after the event as well it's
not gonna be the kind of thing where we
were like oh you only see us when we're
in front of the screen and then or to
talk to us this is the money for the
tickets all goes to the theaters that
way we can just have the space for that
day but this is just a chance for you
guys to come out do our first sort of
meet-and-greet you know whatever the
hell youtubers call those things gonna
be a fun time also which John a happy
birthday in the comments and give John a
birthday present coming to our live
event we're pretty nervous about it we
haven't really been promoting it so yeah
come out anyway death stranding which is
apparently the term for what whales and
sea life do when they wash up on the
beach to die interesting so happen when
you're trying to research Ford estrella
thing I learned darn I have played the
first four Metal Gear games so Hideo
Kojima is someone we're a fan of oh yeah
let's do this
good thing we're not children the hell
was I think we were breaches the man who
delivers
Cheers
chiral energy so you have dudes like me
looks just like Andrew Lincoln what's
your level I've got the extension I
don't but I think you got me beat you
can see them right no but I can satisfy
when it come work for me
must be tough out here on your own and I
can't help you with that
I make deliveries no I've spent seeing a
lot more complicated man that's how I
get from India's game you know Norman
Reedus no they're like those boots are
someone hanging out of the hood
someone has stuffed into that place
[Music]
whoa
but I think they're in Saudi they're
growing
[Music]
sporty character is gonna look this
huge-ass thing under back your room all
the time
[Music]
it's just a lot I get horrible words
them yeah like the ray drops on the
camera oh yeah that's cool I mean the
physics alone
[Music]
Alecto
[Music]
so much
Oh God
oh that was just exploring an open-world
game but the point is to make your own
map
he's got some nipple chills
Earl whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like anihilation meets prometheus
yeah
[Music]
give me your hand into ten what's
yourself those things never stay gone
for them the time for fast forwards
whatever it touches but it can't wash
everything away pastors won't let go
I'll see you around no closing in on my
position I have to move before they
realize I'm in here sure I got an idea
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
where are they wake up baby
[Music]
this looks like a very hard game I know
who looks like a very ancient
[Music]
if you like speaking before
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
a crypto wired a day keeps the time for
all the way yeah you're too late
I still don't know who I am do you
oh yeah
[Music]
around who is this
[Music]
fun
yeah yeah it looks like a blast yeah
actually a really fun game if there's
anyone who is one of the game developers
game creators who has mastered the art
of making their games feel like cinema
its Hideo Kojima yeah all those
cutscenes arguably longer than 13 hours
of cutscenes seven hours of gameplay
what's funny about the marketing for
death stranding cuz this is I think the
third trailer we had four deaths
stranding second or third it's being
advertised in a way how they would
advertise certain movies which is all
tone and style and world knew what are
you gonna be spending time doing in this
game not just like a few flash image
grab your attention or plot because
there's no like what is this I don't
grasp this concept even at the end you
don't have to do one of those like
string explanation am I gonna understand
this game by the time I'm done playing
it too little that's my concern is well
I'd just be wildly confused by the end
of it even at the m-word when she's like
you still know who I am do you then it
turns to her and I had that feeling of
oh it's her oh and I was conveying the
emotions and the mood that our
characters are this is being marketed in
the way how you would advertise them
even like they're saying voice like the
cash it feels like a cinematic trailer I
thought the first half of the shadows
are fascinating because I forgot about
all that other stuff we saw in previous
trailers it's clearly a sci-fi tale my
impression is that these things that
appear like demonic and whatever are not
really demons they're probably some type
of scientific explanation for
aberrations or something like that you
know trying to pick up little context
clues or something I don't know what
time fold means to this game but that
makes me think of like alternate reality
theories or something so like maybe
there are parts where time is sort of
bleeding into other time and then you
have these handprints that are maybe
like you know from people just across
the veil or something I don't know and
that was cool in the first half of this
trailer our characters are just
wandering exploring hugging heavy stuff
when you see a lot of these e3 shows
what's the main thing that we all hype
on graphics landscapes and tone exactly
yeah no doubt about it this all looks
amazingly beautiful I think the biggest
difference with this trailer out of the
other ones we've checked out so far and
you know we got more to upload to we
edit these so I felt like in the first
half like oh we're just chilling with
these guys in this life sitting around
we're in the it's called death stranding
and you get that vibe of death is around
the corner they got these you're all
alone you don't feel like anybody's say
no it doesn't feel safe you're just
exploring the lifestyle what they got to
deal with you know I think of Metal Gear
Solid where you could choose the many
items of guns and everything to be that
they could always do when you press like
l2 or r2 and then here just dragging it
equip your baby yeah which I wonder
about that too like are you growing
people or something like that cuz the
trailer starts out with baby in the womb
and then later on you've got a baby in
your jug thing yeah later and still they
have like a dude in the backpack so I
was in one of those stories where
they've gone to another planet to try to
you know populate or these the last few
humans in this realm we're trying to
repopulate or something death the thing
that consumes life and then the babies
of the last chance they have it's you
know maybe this is your medius and maybe
you are they're just creating people and
we are the gods this feels like
Prometheus annihilation with a hint of
children of men because of the baby part
yeah it looks immersive that's that's
the big thing I II I get from it is this
feels like a patient experience it looks
like it would be really cool in VR cuz
you don't have like the madcap intensity
that makes you not want to put on a VR
headset but you know still it looks
sufficiently scary to make that exciting
but also just you know immersive and
beautiful enough to wear
I would want to have that all around my
head I feel like what Hideo Kojima's
good doing is building tension too and
when you're wandering alone by yourself
you're stranded alone and then when you
encounter an obstacle with some type of
scary thing I imagine that when you
actually get to those points it's gonna
be more scary because you kind of just
been alone for a lot of yeah I think the
marketing for this is brilliant because
I don't feel like anyone actually knows
100% what this is about I bet there's a
lot of great theories out there as to
what this game is all about however I
can't recall a game where it's like a
Nolan film or a g8 leading with the
mystery of what is that now looks great
what I don't know it's kind of intense
it's scary but maybe I don't know and
there's one moment where you do pull out
a gun so I gotta assume that there's
some element of combat involved in this
especially for video games it's still
kind of a new and shiny thing to have a
star-studded cast yeah and you have the
run over from silent Hills with just the
Guillermo del Toro and Norman Reedus
presents building up the hype that much
more video kijima president today yeah
guys why don't you leave in the comment
boxes what you think this game is about
y'all can't subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification velka's
subscribe buttons are rather broken
these days check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions a weekly
Q&A a music video coverage you can
become a patron eject today happy
birthday to John and John what do you
want them to do for your birthday I
would love for you guys to keep an eye
out for a Reena Sinha lounge event and
and buy it ticket and come check it out
that's what I would like to say the
wrong thing not the fleshlight I would
like a copy of I want a death stranding
fleshlight these like tentacles
important that's coming out